c'est leur petit cadeau du lundi une
partie de foot en guise d'échauffement
et pourtant avec les risques de
blessures aux chevilles et l'exercice
n'est pas forcément très apprécié du
coach fabien courtial
mais en bon père de famille il faut
parfois savoir lâcher du lest
pourquoi il joue au foot alors déjà
parce qu'ils aiment beaucoup ça alors
les entraîneurs font pas toujours ce
qu'ils aiment les joueurs mais on a un
petit deal simplement voilà quand on a
gagné le vendredi ils ont ils gagnent
une minute de plus on est à trois
victoires de suite donc ils ont 13
minutes de foot en mise en route ça on
l'a on l'a dans notre arsenal et on
n'utilise pas à la limite c'est un but
quasi quasi sûr analyse vidéo
multiplication des combinaisons à
digérer on ne lésine pas sur la tactique
et sur les détails chez les substances
de sarran donc ça c'est super on a passé
en croire mi temps voilà une sortie du
bloc on renverse et on gagne un budget à
1,5 million d'euros dont deux tiers
consacré à la masse salariale avec nancy
saran est l'un des poids lourds de la
deuxième division du handball français
l'objectif est donc très clair remonter
en lidl starleague au plus vite
plus de deux ans après l'avoir quittée
l'instant on est dans les dents les
places de play-offs qui sont l'objectif
pour essayer de tenter de rejoindre
l'élite à la fin de la saison ce
discours ferme et claire entretenu par
fabien courtial est assimilée par les
joueurs est relayée sur le terrain par
le capitaine emblématique
hadrien ramond là on monte en puissance
car malgré tout
du coup voilà après il faut qu'on essaye
de soigner nos temps faibles je trouve
que depuis le début de l'année on a
quand même pas mal de temps faibles
depuis quelques matchs notre défense est
un point fort clairement mais du coup de
l'autre côté on perd un peu la tacc donc
avant c'était l'attaqué la défense et du
coup ça serait bien qu'on trouve cet
équilibre là pour justement aller gagner
tous ses matches et pour trouver cet
équilibre sans le soutien du public
les substances peuvent compter sur
nicolas gauthier un des meilleurs
gardiens de la pro league ou encore sur
leur demi centre belge tom robbins quand
tu fais un sport collectif
tu as bien dans le contact tu as
toujours une atmosphère de club qui est
très agréable surtout ici ce que j'ai vu
ce que j'ai entendu du club
c'est vraiment un club très familial et
là ça me manque aussi les matches à huis
clos a normalement tu as toujours là
supporters pour pousser un peu quand ça
dure et là ça ça manque
[Musique]
en attendant donc le retour des
supporters lesseps torse n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de gagner pour finir
premiers de la saison et s'offrir
quelques minutes en plus de football